this is the day I die yes he doesn't
quite work as a cold open if I'm not
actually dead by the end of this does it
although boy just late a lot of suspense
in there so hey finale for series two of
Doctor Who the two-parter army of ghosts
and doomsday so boy this is one this is
one I was looking forward to but also
very nervous about because I do enjoy it
and I know that I like it but I also
know that every time i rewatch it I
remember the little things that don't
quite work that I tend to forget which I
think speaks both to sort of a little
bit of weakness of the story but also
sort of the nature of Russell T Davies
as a storyteller and sort of his way of
approaching Doctor Who because whereas
Moffat later on will become much more
interested in sort of the little
mechanisms you know the narrative tricks
and also the sort of nuts and bolts
Davis was always much more focused on
the bigger emotional picture so that it
was not uncommon coming away from a
Davis scripted episode to go you know I
couldn't pick the heck out of it but I'm
not sure I want to because that was a
lot of fun and how to go and had a good
emotional impact and he's kind of
counting on the emotional weight of what
he's done to gloss over other issues and
sometimes it does and sometimes it
doesn't I feel it does here but what are
some of those issues I let's acknowledge
that well let's start with the top the
whole framing thing of Rose on the beach
and the whole this is the this is the
story where I die or whatever it is is
completely unnecessary and stupid and
pointless and honestly I forget that
it's in there until I watch it again
like
it was completely unnecessary I know
they were trying to instill a sense of
dread around this episode but I actually
think it plays much better if her
getting stuck in the parallel world
wasn't for shallow Bush for shallowed
foreshadowed all to heck I mean granted
they foreshadowed her death which is
also got a cheap thing where it's like
oh well you're listed among the dead
because they never found you that's
really dumb and but then beyond that
just foreshadowing that something Bad's
gonna happen to her I don't think
improves the impact of that moment I
think that moment will play better as a
complete rug pull and them and the
moment of her getting trapped over there
does work very well let me be clear
but like that whole thing at the front
end not necessary and doesn't help um
it's funny I was prepared to go off on
one about the previously on from the
previous episode or not previously on a
next time on from the previous episode
which was fear her because that had you
know little bits of just showing the
Cybermen in it and normally I'd have
complained about that except that the
Cybermen do actually show up about 15
minutes in which is pretty early into
the run time so I'm okay with that
thankfully they didn't spoil the Dalek
showing up because that was that was a
good reveal especially you know this
early in the shows life where we're not
yet used to the patterns of a course
they come back they always come back and
they come back every single freaking
year so it was kind of nice to to see
them brought back in a way that wasn't
yet being undercut by the repetitiveness
of the Daleks coming back which sort of
impacts later stories a little bit um
what else we got so in terms of like
there's like little weird quirks of the
pacing of the story
so like Tennant waves a little white
flag in front of the Cybermen and says
he surrenders and then next time we see
him he's just strolling in talking to
the Daleks and then he like blows open a
door and the Cybermen come and start
fighting the Daleks like I'm gonna
assume
because there's no other conclusion for
me to draw that he somehow talked the
Cybermen into teaming up with him but
that's honestly a really big leap to
request an audience to make from the
point at which we last saw the doctor to
the point at which we next see him and
what had to happen in between that's all
that's a big dot to leave to the
audience to connect on their own I'm not
sure it totally works um at least will
you stop and think about it because
again Dave is so it does work in the
sense of it's such a yeah a moment that
you don't really necessarily stop and
think about it unless you're doing it on
a rewatch like I do although I do
remember noticing that before we get
Torchwood which is kind of interesting
how it's played out here and the the
various people within it it's very you
know it feels like a very we're just
here to do the job plus you know the one
person at the top who's very into the
patriotism of it all we get we get a bit
of Jackie and Pete you know I don't
remember ever being kind of choked up on
a little bit touched about the two of
them meaning for the first while this
version of Jackie and this version of
Pete meeting for the first time but now
that worked surprisingly well there was
something about their the conflict that
each of them had about knowing this
wasn't truly the same person who they
loved and lost but it is so close that
they can't help but get swept up in it I
that was surprisingly touching so that
was nice Mickey back awesome and there's
just like like I said there's there's a
lot of little things that are just a
little bit off the the whole thing with
the ghosts and people you know except me
and Jackie even being like why do you
have to spoil it why can't it be real I
don't know if Davies is like trying to
make a jab at at faith not specifically
like you know a specific religion but
like faith in general the idea of you
know wanting to believe so hard it feels
like he thought he had a point there but
it's just kind of there
isn't really developed into much of
anything there's well there's the
there's the offhanded dig on Harriet
Jones but you don't care for cuz I think
Harry Jones got the short shrift by this
show and by this doctor we get sort of
the first instance of a lone Z and sort
of his little fascination with it which
was cool I forgot it had originated with
this one and I mean overall this is just
a lot of fun
this doesn't as after the Daleks get
revealed this doesn't really do anything
unexpected it doesn't really do anything
unexpected prior to that and it doesn't
really have any more tricks up its
sleeve but it is just fun and it's okay
for something to be fun and also it is
fairly impressive that for something
that is kind of a rollicking good time
that it does still have that emotional
impact of the back end of when Rose is
trapped on the other side of that wall
in the other dimension because it can be
tricky sometimes when something that has
just been you know a rollicking good
time to try and milk you know really
heavy and blatant emotions out of the
audience that can be a hard needle to
thread and I think it does it pretty
well I think part of the reason it does
is because what you realize is that this
was almost kind of the inevitable result
of how Cavalier and blase and treating
everything like it was nothing but a fun
adventure that the doctor and Rose have
been doing for pretty much this whole
series it's not dissimilar to when Clara
passed away the first time in and face
the Raven that felt very much like the
inevitable conclusion of her trying to
be the doctor which was something that
had been alluded to and sort of built up
over the course of that series and I
think there's a similar thing going on
here where people have even pointed out
to them you guys are too you know you
don't take this seriously enough for
what it is that you're doing and this
this consequence feels like a an
inevitable sad conclusion to how they've
been living their lives and I think
that's part of the reason why it worked
that shift works from the fun of seeing
cybermen and daleks just you know shout
at each other
for a few minutes before try and blow
each other off with the more emotional
gut punches of the tail-end so I think
for as much as I I will always say this
series is very up-and-down and very
uneven and very wonky that specific
thread running through that thematic
thing as opposed to you know the mystery
box of ooh Torchwood Torchwood ooh how's
that gonna be which I don't like and I
never have but that sort of thematic
linking and and payoff in the finale
that I actually quite admire and I like
that quite a bit I'm not sure I've got
too much else to say about it it's it's
just a good time with a strong emotional
conclusion and a lot of like little
bumps in the middle that in your at
least for me and my memory they smooth
out basically within minutes of me
finishing having watched an episode of
it or having you know finished watching
this story like yeah there were pause
but like I can't remember them now they
don't seem that important and what
you're left with is the sense of fun and
the sadness and that's what ultimately
should linger so um and while I would
never claim that this is the best series
finale I do think it's a very successful
one especially for what it was trying to
do and at least speaking personally for
the what it leaves behind because what
it leaves behind is the feelings and the
emotions and not the nitpicks at least
not for me so that wraps up series to
doomsday and the army of ghosts this
two-parter oh oh god I'll just mention
this real quick cuz this is like a weird
thing for me we also have Freema Agyeman
you know here not playing Martha later
revealed to be Martha's cousin what
with movies and TV shows the concept of
identical cousins are like identical you
know relatives but who aren't twins
that's like that's such a movie and TV
thing and it's it's ridiculous and I
know like she I pretty sure she hadn't
been cast as as Martha yet at the time
that that she was cast into this but
it's just it's so ridiculous anyway what
are your thoughts on it whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about a whole bunch of stuff
down there too because there's buttons
and links including went to the patreon
the support is greatly appreciated helps
keep this thing going I've got the PIO
box there's other links to check out
besides but if you don't want to look at
any of them that's okay cuz at the end
of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]